hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I'm just checking in on you just
checking in to see how you're doing man
[__] by the way you know also checking
in specifically if they can [__]
still hear me anybody who's stuck around
in North Carolina Virginia wherever else
the Carolinas I ain't [__] going
anywhere goddamn it I got a [__] bass
boat alright that I turn I took the
[__] camper off the back of my camper
special I welded it to my [__] bass
boat I am good to go I'd like to see a
[__] Gator come along my way all
right I have a feast and a new pair of
[__] shoes water moccasins I'll make
you into a [__] belt bring it on
mother nature
you [__] [__] that's what a lot of
people that's what a lot of people think
people who are not leaving despite all
of the warnings are thinking that's what
they think is going on right I'll put on
a pair of [__] snowshoes and I'll
walk right across the [__] class oh
they're spinning I don't give a [__] I
drink moonshine spinning is my natural
state [__]
mother nature coming over here like some
sort of [__] ex-wife wanting more
[__] money a lot of people think that
that's what's going on but you know
people don't understand that what the
bankers did in the 2000s is still
affecting people and there's a lot of
people who are still upside down in a
house that's never gonna be worth more
than what they're that what they owe the
American Dream is over for these people
and when you're in that situation you
know that leads to driving a
piece-of-shit car at least do a whole
bunch of [__] you don't have health
insurance and all of that so now you're
supposed to get into your [__] you
know questionable car and just drive a
state away with no [__] money you
know you got kids you got all of this
[__] what are you gonna do and I know on
the other side people go oh well you
know you get
we should be alive you know what I would
do now that I'm driving drying safe I
would just drive to a Waffle House and I
would sit in the parking lot you know
what would happen the security guard at
the Waffle House there's no security
there's no security they just have a Fay
of a Batphone to the cops at the Waffle
House the Waffle House they have got to
have the most [__] altercations at any
just I mean it's just such a wonderful
place you go in there to get this
delicious unhealthy [__] food that
just it's comfort food you know and what
happens every I swear to God I don't
care who the [__] you are black white
male female Asian [__] into Ron deck
you go in there you're you're [__]
gonna get into a fight you're gonna see
a fight you're gonna have to pick up
your [__] waffles and move it out of
the way if somebody slams down on your
table like you're in some sort of
[__] saloon in the 1800s you're
telling me these people in North Carroll
acting are supposed to drive to that
[__] parking lot well bill don't you
think that's better than trying to wait
it out in a hurricane I don't know dude
I've never had to do that you know
fortunately I'm not in that financial
[__] position but uh you know I just
don't understand how these [__]
bankers got away with that Joe I
understand how they did it and they're
doing it again
but these luxury high-rise apartment
buildings that they're [__] building
everywhere what kind of a [__]
jerk-off rents a luxury high-rise
apartment building okay don't do that
buy a piece-of-shit house okay at least
at the end of living there you can sell
it and get some of your money back you
may or may not make a profit but I'm
just saying you know all you
instagramers you know what's really
interesting that I didn't realize do you
know old Millennials are everybody is
looking at myself included you look at
college kids these [__] Millennials
they they can't do anything for
themselves they're not Millennials
all right Millennials the first
Millennials you know what year they were
born 1980 okay - 19 I think 95 so
Millennials right now are 22 to 38 and I
imagine there's some other uninformed
heads like me out there who are 38 years
old and talking about people who are 18
calling them [__] Millennials when
they are not Millennials but the person
is saying it is actually a [__]
millennial alright people now you got to
know what generation you're talking
about like you know it's funny I'm
actually Generation X so I was after the
baby boomers and that ended in like I
don't know 63 or 64 or something like
that and then Generation X went up to
1979 and what's funny is I did not I did
I I don't identify as gen x no
generation next to me was the Seattle
music scene that's when I started
[__] here in it I don't think enough
but I didn't think the baby boomers were
like hey man we got to get out of
Vietnam man [__] baby killer man
right I feel like this should be a
generation between baby boomers and
Generation X you know that generation
that like Ronnie James Dio you know but
you know didn't listen to the Mamas and
the Papas all the leaves are brown and
the sky is great like that [__] um I'd
like to watch your mama cats dance she
had a [__] cool little two-step she
used to do anyways I don't know what the
[__] I'm talking about right now I'm
just saying you know good luck to all of
those people I'm coming in next week
if it's not under [__] water I really
hope it isn't and you know I don't know
this it's crazy this is just [__]
crazy
I know we always had hurricanes and
stuff but like I just hope they're not
going to keep getting worse and the
sheer amount of them you know there's
nothing worse than watching people lose
everything right if only there was a way
to fix this the Mother Nature is trying
right now
trying with the only the quickest
swiftest [__] solution that's
literally you know metaphorically what
she's doing right now going I see what
the problem is I need to drown some of
these [__] I need to drown a
certain amount of him right but she's
gonna have to the scary thing is she's
gonna have to do way better than what
she's doing right now because we always
warn everybody out right the storms
coming and everybody gets the [__] out
of Dodge
so mother nature's got to be walking
around just shaking her head after every
one of these things going I'm telling I
know it does make any [__] sense
she's like mr. pink you know tell me we
got a [__] rat okay when those alarms
go off you you've got 15 minutes I'm
telling the cops it was just there man
they were just there already all loaded
for bear I know I'm alright I'm [__]
positive you look I gotta watch that
movie again um yeah mother Nate's got B
we got a [__] rat in the house okay so
who's uh who was Tim Roth tarantino's
mr. brown like mr. [__] mr. pink mr.
blonde mr. white mr. orange yeah she has
to find out who her mister oranges and
her mr. orange is the [__] Weather
Channel you know she's got to come in
there so you like to tell jokes huh
giggling like a bunch of girls at a
school yeah well I got a joke for you
anyways I have been working out I've
been eating right and I got to tell you
guys I'm in like the [__] best shape
I've been in in in years and it is
[__] unbelievable I know people
always told me diet it's it's 90% dydz
95 to 85 percent 70 percent die dude
it's it's all diet it's all diet because
like if you can go kick the [__] out of
yourself and a goddamn gym jump on a
[__] elliptical you jump on an
elliptical and eating for an hour burns
600 calories according to that [__]
computer which how the [__] it knows how
much you're burning versus somebody else
you know whatever it so it's an estimate
so you give sweat all over the [__]
thing you don't wipe it off because
you're a selfish [__] you go walking out
of there right and then later on that
night all you gotta have like three and
a half four Oreo cookies and you just
negated that workout done all of that
[__] work out the window and you can
you can [__] just look at a minute a
half you know it's like it's like every
yeah when we whenever you put out these
seasons of f is for family it takes us
like [__] 14 months to finish them
and then people just not saying you know
that's how kids watch it I'm just saying
then they just come back like hey man
like when's the next season coming same
thing same thing I went out I'm actually
like I am off sugar and salt to the
point I asked my wife to go out and get
some almond butter and she got it and I
already knew there was something going
on with it where it says you didn't have
to stir this [__] I'm like this doesn't
sound like the GNAT just doesn't feel
like the natural [__] so I put it in
this smoothie two tablespoons of this
[__] and I mean I say that's this
[__] sugar in this and after like for
like five weeks I've been eating like
this like it literally almost made my my
[__] I mean like like I bit into a
lemon like Jesus Christ and I never
noticed that before hands so if you're
old like me and you want to regain some
of your old glory you want to drive down
the street with your hair slicked back
you want to put the top down
you want to tell these [__] what time
it is um it's all about diet your abs
are there man if you didn't have I don't
have abs yes you do if you didn't have
abs you could not sit up in bed you know
you couldn't even roll out of bed you
need your obliques
you could not roll out of bed to go
downstairs you need a chocolate chip
muffin or whatever other stupid thing
that you're gonna do that's gonna make
you break a blood vessel when you
[__] sit down you know let's sit down
that you do when you get really out of
shape where you lose you use your leg
muscles and at some point it just
becomes a freefall into the couch you
give yourself whiplash and your [__]
head hits the table that your wife just
had to have that was just a little bit
higher than the couch you look nice and
now you're in a fight right and now
you're going to work telling you friends
that you're not getting along with your
wife and what a [__] [__] she is and
all of this type of [__] and what it
really comes down to is you just you're
not eating right you're not eating right
so you literally have to do a trust fall
into your [__] couch you get a
[__] mild concussion on the giant end
table that she just had just had to have
it and he's like for what I'm loving the
aunt in southern accent lately it kind
of disguises that it's actually my own
ignorant saying it oh no I was just
doing a character I was just doing a
character oh my god you gotta be kidding
we're nobodies women they don't even
like sports oh they do then why the [__]
are there only eight people at a WNBA
game you explain that to me why aren't
these feminists are Twenties feminists
out there to [__] at the goddamn
whatever they called Oklahoma [__] game
well once you watch an episode of The
Real Housewives maybe you figure out
that's why they don't show up [__] maybe
they're three minutes they'd be [__]
lunging over a goddamn table ain't give
me no cameraman they're not enough
cameraman to break it up I went down a
Randy Newman rabbit hole the other night
Jesus Christ that guy he's talented huh
and one that's I'm old enough to
remember in that song show up people got
no reason sure people God job people God
no and that came out and all these short
people got man and he was he was making
fun of racism the ridiculousness of
racism right they got little cars go
beep beep beep that got little voices
going Pete Pete Pete grubby little hands
dirty little minds people once again
took it at face value but you know
having said that that song came out and
then there was a bunch of people that
didn't get what it was about and they
were singing it too short people so I
don't know it was so brilliant on so
many different levels and I loved his
voice I loved the piano he plays and
he's done all these all these great
songs for movies and stuff like that I
actually looked up to see if he was
touring anywhere there's some really
great footage of him to actually with
that short people thing where he's in
the studio like an incredible credible
sense of humor you know as most you know
geniuses that I've seen always self like
deprecating and that type of stuff it's
really funny how that is you know people
who stink just walk around like like
they're [__] astronauts just supreme
confidence you know always thinking they
killed it just no [__] clue it's just
like it's just one of those [__]
things you know I don't know that's
always a red flag to me but someone's
walking around oh maybe that's my own
[__] thing
maybe that's the Boston thing like easy
there kid don't forget where you came
from [__] relax
easy there Travolta anyways uh what else
what else is there to talk about
I've just been yeah I was you know it
was [__] amazing I was watching this
episode last night Sunset Strip and they
showed the Cahuenga Pass which is where
the 101 goes from Hollywood into the
valley and there's this old bridge and
they were showing like footage of it
from the 1950s and I'd seen this before
at a car dealership that had all these
old pictures of Hollywood and you see on
the 101 between the 101 north and one on
101 South at the Cahuenga passes in
between there are railroad tracks that
no longer exist and it's always like you
know they used to they the city Believe
It or Not from what you know the tree
huggers save me on had one of the
greatest public transportations of any
city and the conspiracy theory is that
the oil company companies in Goodyear
Tire created a corporation and they
bought up all the streetcars all the
trains and all the trolleys and all that
type of [__] they bought it up and just
ripped up all the tracks paved over
everything and forcing people to all
have to drive so then they like they
would make so much [__] money that
they could buy a business as big as that
with trains who can afford to throw out
of one [__] train forget about a
whole city full of them streetcars and
trolleys and all that ripped up all the
[__] tracks I mean I don't know what
happened but there's something happened
cuz it may it makes no sense
you know streetcars were the best they
know they still have them in like San
Francisco and I want to talking about
the stupid one where you go up the
[__] hill like you were I mean those
old school the ones that I grew up
seeing
I don't know but they're actually there
they're building they are building
public transportation out here again so
we shall see it's weird though because
everything then got built up like
everybody had a car so like most
buildings just to go from the sidewalk
to the building is like you ever go to
Vegas and you're like oh I'm gonna walk
across the street to this other casino
and like [__] you know 15 minutes
later you're on your hands and knees
going like water water like it's like an
illusion it looks like it's right there
it's right across the street it is so
[__] far away I know the it ceases
what's hilarious is you can go from the
Mirage to the to Caesars and they just
have this moving air-conditioned
sidewalk you know and there's just all
these fat sweaty people on it you know
the things should actually be moving in
the opposite direction should be a giant
treadmill for these people and you
should have to walk on it for ten
minutes
then it shuts off and rolls the other
way you should you shouldn't you should
have to earn it you know there would
just be too much too much liability
somebody has a heart attack somebody
slips and falls so they don't they just
conveyor belt
you know like cattle off to slaughter
Jesus bill why can't it just be people
who are just fat and happy you know
going in you know wearing their favorite
loud shirt to go play some craps you
know what you know I think you guys
might have a point on this one so
anyways the first week of NFL has gone
by now you know what everybody's doing
everybody looks at week one and then
they just say that's who these people
are the New York Jets are they the
favorites in the AFC East they won one
game I tell you the Patriots look good
but all of a sudden the Texan came back
and made it really close if I was a
patriot friend I would be concerned
about that I don't know about you guys
don't you feel like there's about three
weeks in you know you can kind of start
to tell like okay this this team is this
this team is that and then there's you
know injuries you don't know what the
[__] gonna happen
but I really don't think that the Tampa
Bay Buccaneers are gonna put up 48
points a week while letting up 40 are
the Saints gonna let up 48 I don't
[__] know
right Cincinnati gonna go down by 20
every [__] week and then come roaring
back and [__] wait on it maybe they
will maybe this is what's gonna happen
[Music]
okay right now it's Cincinnati I mean if
this is what's most exciting see safer
um anyways so I am going to uh I'm gonna
be in town this whole weekend cuz I have
a I have a bunch of big gigs coming up
so I am touring like I used to tour so I
have like one weekend off until like
towards the end of October and but this
weekend obviously got moved to next
weekend which was my only weekend off so
kind of worked out and so my wife was
going hey I got some stuff to do
Saturday afternoon do you mind you know
hanging out with our daughter and it's
like what why you out of course I don't
of course I wait to hang with my
daughter and watch LSU verse auburn are
you kidding me this is a dream it's a
[__] dream well I ain't gonna be a
dream they got a goddamn broad
announcing the [__] game it would
still be a dream I don't give a [__]
welcome ladies welcome to the world of
broadcasting anyways yeah I can't wait
to might we took our daughter over to
get some shots you know what I mean like
I decided to stop listening to Hollywood
celebrities and actually listen to
people in the medical field so my
daughter is getting all the shots we
stretched him out or whatever so she
went there to get like her shots so
she's been there at numerous times and
so now like she knows when we go in
there that this is the place where she
feels that needle and stuff so she's
like on there she's like you know when I
used to bring my dog to the vet you know
he thinks I'm trying to make a laugh and
stuff so we ended up going in there and
the woman neuroses great she just real
quick gets it done and my daughter said
her first three words sentence after she
got the shot like she was already crying
when we laid back anticipating and then
she got the shot and then she caught she
let out this yell just broke my heart
and then she looked at the nurse and she
just goes oh done bye-bye
like it was so [__] cute and it also
like broke my heart all at the same time
I picked her up and she you know a
little hand grabbing a handful on my
shirt
like Terry o'reilly back in the day but
she's trying to hug me she just kept
looking at the nursery nurse goes it's
all okay that's it yeah all done she
just kept going by by by by was just
like it was like a kid going I don't you
get the [__] away from me man
bye-bye like I can't even I can't even
recreate that moment um it's so wet I
was so glad that I was there as a dad
cuz I gotta be honest with you like I
would stay out in the waiting room
because I I could not handle I was
hearing those babies crying then I was
just like you know I I don't know that I
could I could handle even if it's a good
thing watching somebody on any level
hurting my kid and I know that they're
doing it for the right thing but it was
just like so I went in there and I got
through it and I'm glad I did I was glad
that I did and it was oh my god it was
so [__] cute it was so cute
bye-bye-bye
I just kept saying that like like like
I'm done with you get away from me I
don't want any more of this [__] I just
can't I can't like the emotion in a
voice I just can't put into [__]
words for whatever reason anyway so
let's do some advertising here for the
week my bookie everybody I call him in
every week all right call
do they have a pot I didn't what the
[__] does that call I'm so goddamn busy
I know I call in a couple people I do my
pics here alright my bookie you know
ever since ice this podcast people have
been asking me for advice ask me what
team to bet on the truth is I don't know
I don't know who's gonna win I don't
know [__] I can't even name half the
quarterbacks in the league I keep
forgetting the name of the guy in the
Texans who's [__] incredible Watson
Dante Derek
DeAndre something one of those cool
black ID names Watson but if you think
you know you gotta check out my bookie
remember who you remember who you're
betting on is just as important as who
you betting with god this copy is
written so well and I [__] it up let me
try this again the truth is I don't know
who's gonna win but if you think you
know you gotta check out my bookie
remember who you betting on is just as
important as who you betting with that's
why people always tell you to bet with
my bookie trust them they're your best
bet this season they've been in business
for years they got great reviews online
and their mobile site is easy to use my
bookie you win they pay this isn't in
the copy you lose you pay I mean yeah
obviously if you win they pay well is
that supposed to be like a great thing
holy [__] you actually pay me if I win
Wow finally an honest bookie anyways
they have in game live betting the most
rewarding player perks in the business
and for you fantasy flip pool playing
guys out there you can even bet the
under the over/under on how many fantasy
points a player will score each game
might both attest my favorite [__] the
bet my bookie is other than other than
taking points I love taking points
I love taking the points I love the
underdog you know my bookie is slammed
with new betters and wants to give
everyone the best service possible if
you're willing to deposit after 7:00
p.m. Eastern Time they will give you an
additional an additional $25 free play
on deposits over $100 so many people
using this site they're actually trying
to delay
you delinquents from calling in man so
get an extra 25 bucks if you do it after
7:00 p.m. Eastern Time join now at my
book in my book e will match your
deposit dollar for dollar use promo code
bur be URR to activate the offer that's
visit my visit my bookie online today
that's my bookie my Bo ok ie and don't
forget to use the promo code burr when
creating your account to claim up to
$1,000 in free play and now if you're
willing to hold after 7:00 7:00 p.m. you
get an extra $25 using the promo code
burr bu are our and listen after the
podcast before the throwback clips to my
call into the sports gambling podcast
that's what it is with Sean green and
Ryan Cramer
it says mention who you talked about who
did I talk about we talked about the
Jets we talked about Aaron Raj and what
but kings did we pick this week you know
I don't remember we talked that we
talked to all kinds of football I know I
don't remember I have no I don't have no
idea we talked about the bills you
talked about the dolphin's a lot of AFC
II stuff and then we talked about the
Eagles we talked to we talked football
people all right do you like football
listen to the goddamn podcast all right
he likes everybody hellix there's nobody
on the planet like you so why would you
buy a [__] generic mattress built for
everyone else
next please mention all the talking
points below well I was gonna he wrote
it I'm gonna I'm gonna read it he looks
sleep Malik's matches your body to the
perfect mattress so you get the best
sleep of your life
they developed nine different mattresses
tailored to the specific body types and
sleep preferences just go to helix house
sleep calm / BER to take their two
minutes sleep quiz and then they'll
match you to a mattress that perfectly
fits you contouring to your body to
provide unprecedented comfort and better
sleep you know when you lay in your side
and your beer-bellied just digs into the
mattress they'll have a little concave
spot there just for you and your belly
right you got a lot of chest hair and
you sleep on your stomach they even have
a mattress for that 30
6% of hellix he looks sleek customers
report better sleep after watching
switching to their customized mattress
from helix sleep right now they're
offering up to 125 dollars on all
mattresses whether you're a sad sleeper
a hot sleeper like to a plush or a firm
bed they've got the mattress that will
fit just right I sleep on my back I
later like I'm in a coffin occasionally
on the right shoulder maybe on the left
never on the stomach though my back has
been too [__] up to lay on my stomach
for years for decades I lay my stomach
and then all of a sudden I'm just like
turn over roll out of the bed got to
start stretching anyways get up to $125
you know every time I get on the floor -
I think there's gonna be something under
the bed I never got over that you know
it's weird I'm not really a religious
guy but I definitely some of that go
[__] even though I don't believe in that
either you know what I do and I get on
the floor and I start thinking there's
something looking at me under the bed
you know I get over it
I just give whatever's under the under
the bed to finger you know cuz I figure
if there's something underneath there
and I give it the finger it's gonna kill
me that's gonna be over right and then
if it doesn't do anything I'm like
there's either nuf that underneath there
or it's a [__] it's a [__] [__]
it's a [__] right [__] coaches whether
you're a side sleeper a hot sleeper like
a plush or a firm bed they've got the
mattress that fits you just right get up
$225 off helix helix sleep calm slash
burn that's a Qi Liu calm slash burn for
$125 off your mattress order oh look
who's here but who do do me undies me
undies get the [__] outta Dodge doo doo
doo doo me Andes me undies you're gonna
drown in your Lodge when they tell you
to leave your state drive to a Waffle
House it'll be great and your balls will
be nice and soft and they'll be [__]
dry coz you will be out of the flood
zone then you go back to your moldy
house and look for Sean Penn he'll be
driving around in his
alright me undies you've heard me obsess
over me undies you've heard me talk
about how much they are three times
softer than cotton and come with fun new
prints each month but I got a big scoop
that I'm so excited to share with y'all
the undies just gave their membership a
massive upgrade members will also pay
less for everything on me undies website
with special member pricing that means
if you want a second pair of me undies a
bralette or lounge pants you'll pay less
than anyone else what the [__] are longe
pants I want some the membership I don't
like listen don't send me any man DS
okay I got enough [__] I'm trying to
[__] get rid of stuff lounge pants oh
that's the how do you lay off lounge
pants we ask you mate don't stop for
sweetheart can't you see I'm in my
lounge pads what did we say whenever my
lounge pants at meet some [__]
lounging well maybe I do have to yell
cuz obviously didn't hear it the [__]
first time I'll go to your mother's go
to your mother's she wanted to go there
anywhere yeah how could my mother never
comes over huh all of a sudden we're too
[__] busy one of my relatives right
lounge pants by me on DS you'll pay less
than anyone else the membership comes
with no strings attached
you can switch styles skip the month or
cancel anytime that they come with a
hundred percent satisfaction guarantee
if you don't love them just send them
back for a full refund the undies has a
great offering her for a great offer for
my listeners my listeners for any
first-time purchasers when you purchase
any me undies you get 15% off the free
shipping this is a no get 15% off a pair
of the most comfortable undies you will
ever put on to get your v to get your
15% off your first pair free shipping in
100% satisfaction guaranteed go to me
undies calm / / that's me undies talk
comm / bar Yanni's dot-com / burp
alright that is the podcast
alright the Thursday afternoon podcast
now now you get the little transition
music and then you get a next you get
two extra [__] things here this
is incredible you're gonna get to listen
to me talking to what a hell did it go
um the sports gambling podcast was Shawn
green and Ryan um you get to listen to
my pitch you get to listen my picks of
the week I actually think my lock of the
week was that someone was going to say
something disparaging about the the the
female announcer and I as far as I can
tell nothing really happened you know I
was just funnin right the end of mine I
said good luck to everybody but they
should have a transgendered person in
there [__] do it
booth is longing they still playing
football I don't give a [__] all right
and as long as you know what you're
talking about I don't know what I don't
care what's between your legs what you
used to have there what you attached
what's your carved out I don't I don't
give a [__] just please for the love of
God know what you're talking about and
enhance the experience don't take away
from it right in other words do the
exact opposite of what I do in my
[__] podcast all right have a great
weekend you [__]
let's go LSU actually Randy Newman has a
song called rednecks where he actually
he's actually making fun of northern
liberals when it comes to racism how
everybody acts like you know all the
racism is down south it's a song you
could never write today because of the
lyrics but you know if you actually knew
what he was talking about but there's
this there's a line in there got college
kids at LSU go and um come out dumb too
so I figured people of Alabama would
like to listen to that one right or
maybe Mississippi it's always the state
next-door Arkansas I've noticed like
states always think the state next to
him was [__] stupid and they're
better you know which is why rough and
rowdy is so [__] tremendous they're
the only people I've ever seen that
really exploit that state-to-state
rivalry at the level that people really
want to take it to all right we play
football because it's illegal to just go
and beat the [__] out of each other but
with rough and rowdy like when they had
it down in the Carolinas I had no idea
how much people in South Carolina and
North Carolina didn't care for one
another
you know and
we thought because that because of that
invisible line if you were on the other
side of it that meant that you was some
sort you were less than them
it's [__] tremendous so the next
rough and rowdy event unfortunately I'm
not going to be there but you can bet
good and goddamn well I'm gonna order it
and I'm gonna tape it and I'm gonna sit
down with my Miller High Life sand I'm
gonna watch it the next one I believe is
in Kentucky and it's on October 5th but
I have a gig in Boston that night so I
won't be able to do it but please please
turn on tune in Dave Portnoy big cat and
all those hilarious people over there
alright that is it
enjoy your weekend gee console
[Music]
[Applause]
that's the way you're doing you play the
guitar on the MTV
[Music]
maybe get at the store
bill birnes sports gambling podcast is
brought to you by my bookie Dodd AG my
bookie is the leader in online sports
books use the promo code bill bets for a
hundred percent deposit bonus play win
and get paid at my bookie AG ok joining
us on the line bill burr bill I know I
know you said you had some traveling to
do this past Sunday were you able to
enjoy NFL week one yeah I watched the
Patriots game although my DirecTV was
kind of cutting in and out so I watched
a little bit of that I saw a little bit
of the Jets and I watched John Gruden's
return and I was loving the first half
was great seeing him there I thought it
was funny when we say and he couldn't be
was gonna be able to write to these
younger kids and all the young kids he
is like the oldest team in the NFL
that's either gonna be I think actually
I think it's kind of a genius move on
his part
yeah it seemed to be a bold play to kind
of do what Kurt and did and obviously
the second half didn't work out I mean
last week we hit on it I think you're
locked cash that the every sports
announcer will be coming out with the
sky is falling down and that certainly
seems to be the case for the Raiders and
then on the positive side the Jets well
why don't I mean the Raiders play like
the first half state they were metal was
really good Rams team I mean like the
Raiders have been like like you know a
slapstick show forever
I think week 1 that that was I would be
happy with that if I was a Raiders fan
I'm you know that second they didn't
look clueless I mean it's only week one
yeah I know and the Jets are now like
you know they're already you know Sam
whatever that USC guy did yeah they're
like you know what he did week one that
Tom Brady did this person it's just like
you know I'm not saying that that guy
isn't gonna be great or anything but
like like I don't think you really even
know what's going on until after three
weeks as far as just like alright I mean
look at that that Tampa Saints game
forty eight forty I mean is that what
they're gonna be doing each week I don't
know
forty or the other way around at this
that just seems like sometimes it's just
weird games and I don't like Stafford's
gonna throw five interceptions he just
you know but sometimes you just have a
bad game and I don't know that was there
was that Jets game it was you know I
mean obviously if they do that every
week they're gonna be world beaters but
I get a feeling that they're not going
to be yeah I agree and just as a as a
someone who grew up as the Jets as like
the little brother team just listening
them chant J ETS jet jet it's like calm
down one win and that the worst
heartache of the week so far is the you
know Brett Favre's first pass in the NFL
was an interception to say calm down
calm down there there's too many
channels they have to overhype
everything but what the Jets did was
obviously really impressive and I you
know I mean AFC East guys so Miami want
to win that Buffalo good world so yeah
Buffalo good lord they ever gonna turn
it around no it's only one week who
knows but I mean well you know it's
funny that they sent out the Patriots
for the first time since 2016 or not
favorites next week and I'm I was sick
of like what 2016 isn't that long ago
you know I mean I guess it is as far as
like you know being a favorite all of
those all of those games but you know
they made it seem like it was gonna be a
decade ago yeah yeah I mean New England
that they came out they took care of
business against the Texans it wasn't it
was it was kind of it was it was a weird
game it didn't it you never thought the
Patriots were gonna lose but the spread
seemed like it might come into a play a
Gronk obviously looking great I kind of
like you know I was very impressed with
their defense
you know containment of their
quarterback weight never remember its
friggin name why not
yeah Watson but our special
kind of led up a lot of yards it seems
like every time they ran it back they
got at least to the 30 I don't know we
shall see but our defense looks pretty
solid well you know it's only one week
well they they finally got rid of
Patricia man took that garbage defense
to Detroit oh man how yeah I mean if
you're if you're a Lions fan and you
watch the Super Bowl and then week one
Monday night against the New York Jets
you could not be happy it's like you
brought in the defensive coordinator the
defense sucked yes and you kept the
offensive coordinator if you like the
chemistry and they look like horrible
[__] so I don't know a lot of good
regression angles in the NFL for yeah
exactly I mean that's when you're
talking about bet in the NFL that's what
you that's kind of what you have to do
you have to look to opportunities to
fade some crazy outcome like you said
Bill with the the Bucs putting up 48
points on the road I have a feeling Ryan
Fitzpatrick isn't gonna do that week to
just just gut instinct there's a reason
he's not doing that every week it's it's
a fluke crazy [__] yeah yeah it's there
was yeah it was definitely a weird it's
a lot of weird games but what's funny is
I one of the things I bet on this season
is there will be no tie this see I won
on it last year the first week of the
season BAM and of course it's the
[__] Browns
yeah it paid like one and a half to one
it just seems like there's an it like
you said there's never a tie even now
with only the 10 minute overtime it
seems like it's a it's the NFL you're
not gonna end in a tie come on yeah they
should switch it to the college football
the rules for overtime because that's
such a more exciting way to finish the
game and then you never end up with the
tie no so I bet a hundred and I would
win 150 plus my original bet back so it
felt it felt like the right I mean I
don't you know obviously it's a losing
bet so hindsight is is what it is but
yeah ties are just both teams really
tried to lose the game that's what yeah
we were we were actually out in Las
Vegas hanging out in the sports book
they missed that field goal to end the
game in a tie it was the sports looks
great for dramatic wins and losses but
dramatic ties it's just no one's happy
even if you had Cleveland plus three and
a half you still wanted to see them hit
that field goal just just to end the
suffering it was like we were at a strip
club and a dude walk down this is their
best start and over what 14 that starts
since 2004 which man they were loving
that step all right well let's uh let's
get into some of these spreads of course
the spreads are brought to you by my
bookie dad AG the one of the safest
online sports books use the promo code
bill Betts for a hundred percent deposit
bonus they got it all over there in-game
wagering the prop builder play win and
get paid my bookie dad AG promo code
bill bets
alright first game to talk about New
England Patriots they head into
Jacksonville where the Jaguars right now
RA the Pats actually are favored in this
game they're a three point favorite
right now Jack yeah Jags are the home
dog here we're looking at a rematch of
the AFC Championship although it was
played in New England and not
Jacksonville bill are you worried about
the the Jags defense here on the road
you know obviously he's beating us twice
in Super Bowls and everything look how
quickly he's turned that team around
everywhere the guy goes if they you know
Franklin back as days when he's bought
the cows I'm a big fan of and three
points at home I would take I would take
the jack I wouldn't be afraid I would
take the Jaguars getting three at home
you know I just think they were a really
tough team and we'll see we'll see I
mean obviously I'm for the Patriots but
we're talking money here exactly
chemists are trying to keep the light
yeah it does feel like that's the smart
play I mean you touched on it last week
Sean the Patriots generally aren't
playing their best ball in September and
guess what this is the biggest game on
the schedule for the Jags yeah I'm
blowing that game in New England so I
mean look the Pats let a Houston team
that played pretty poorly get back in
the game and Watson was not himself so
I'm gonna I'll say unless bortles
completely bortles it
I think the Jags Jags are gonna win this
game yeah it and you talk about Tom
Coughlin style the way to beat New
England is the to try and get pressure
on Tom Brady with just using your
defensive line and not blitzing a bunch
of guys that you know the Jags have that
strong defensive line that might be able
to well might not dominate the game but
certainly pressure Brady enough and I
think what the the Pats have going for
them is Leonard fournette
looks like he's gonna be out for the
Jags Jags don't have a ton of offensive
weapons honestly I think the play in
this game may be maybe to go under feels
like it's gonna be a little slug match
here but I'll take the Jags catching
three in a rematch at home yeah I know
God hates a Jag remember that I always
get nervous I mean boy if you want to
fade recency just take the under in
every game I feel like they're the
they're perhaps maybe an over adjustment
to the totals after that yeah everything
I mean the the fantasy everything the
scoring was just off the charts yeah it
is it is tough to bet the under I mean
just for the entertainment value alone
to just root against every play to
succeed but I don't think anybody's ever
gonna break Emmitt Smith's all-time
rushing record they just did you
opportunities just aren't there anymore
no yeah I mean it's I think it's gonna
be really hard for any running backs to
set marks going forward cuz I mean half
their touches are gonna be passes he's
gonna be like that guy who's won the
most games like whoever won the most
games in MLB history it's gonna it's
gonna seem that daunting like there was
a different error
yeah siyoung has over 800 starts they're
not doing that anymore now they yeah I
mean they're never gonna you'd come even
close to getting there yeah you pitch a
whole doubleheader back then though they
take giant cigar cause look at Babe Ruth
he does he does strike you as your uncle
at a softball game we can just crush it
who just had a little bit of hand-eye
coordination yeah I used to play in a
softball team when I was working in a
warehouse and he always had these these
ringers would come out they all look
built like Babe Ruth's little skinny
legs big just get up and they would turn
that torso and the thing would go a mile
yeah that's like I mean that was Cecil
Fielder you know he was he was the
modern-day version of that meal all
right next up we got the New York Giants
heading down to Dallas right now it's
sitting at a even -3 here
both teams started out Owen one neither
neither looked great - uh yeah I mean
Giants lost at home to the Jags Cowboys
lost on the road to the Panthers spill
which way you lean in here it's just
like like the Cowboys home it's a close
I think you beat us twice so I mean I
keep the Dez Bryant hangover in this
hole whatever the hell they've done
Reformation of the Cowboys is the
hangover at last for at least three
weeks I'm going with the Giants Cramer
I'm assuming you're gonna be back in
your chance I also believe in Eli I
appreciate all these mentions of Tom
Coughlin and the Super Bowl wins
and you should see how excited riders
get on the other end of this but I mean
here's the thing right I think I was
talking to my dad today and I was like
yeah you know I actually wasn't that
upset the Giants played fine they played
a really good team they played a really
good defense more importantly and their
offensive players got theirs they just
they were picked six away so but what I
would they saw in the Dallas Cowboys
game was a team that even when Kuechly
was out of the game this team struggled
to do anything and dak as we know Shaun
Dakota Prescott not the best quarterback
in the NFL so now Eli has historically
played well in Dallas I'm gonna keep
throwing that out there and yeah no of
course you take the take the Giants
before it gets off a three yeah as much
as it pains me I'm gonna take this I'm
gonna take the Giants getting three
points you look at the Cowboys they're
only they got seek and that's it their
offensive line isn't the dominant force
that it was and they they have no skill
positions to help deck out on that
offense I think they're just gonna have
trouble putting up points and the Giants
their weakness is the offensive line
obviously the Jags were able to exploit
that I don't see the Cowboys being able
to get enough pressure on Eli and listen
it is Sunday night Sunday Night Football
I think your buddy Odell riding in spite
of the fact that he has not won a game
since he went on the infamous boat trip
I think they get a victory down in down
in Dallas Stadium there so I'll take the
Giants plus three I don't feel great
about it because Dallas coming off at a
loss maybe they rally but I am just
still not a believer in Jason Garrett at
all as a head coach
I think Dakota Prescott sounds like some
country singer on one of those American
Idol shows so true I mean it's just it's
it cracks me up his name's Dakota vote
now for Dakota Prescott it's the fact
that he's also Prescott yeah you could
you could be Dakota something or
something Prescott but Dakota Prescott
that's a tough one man just like you're
just born with an acoustic guitar and a
cowboy hat yeah you imagine it's a yeah
he's like a chick with a cut-off flannel
shirt with some like short jean shorts
coming out with the acoustic guitar
ready to wow you with their latest
rendition
that's another way of looking at it I
didn't Daisy well he's he is he is a
woman in my scenario bill he's done Sean
let's not forget the dak Prescott to
Kesari Dakota's Prescott favorite song
is drops of Jupiter by Jane that was a
little-known nugget about Dakota that
was the trivia fact we dug up all right
last game of the week that will be
breaking down here Kansas City Chiefs
coming off a nice win on the road
against this the Los Angeles chargers
now they're heading into Pittsburgh
obviously Pittsburgh coming off that
ugly ugly tie against the Cleveland
Browns right now my bookie has the
Pittsburgh Steelers as -5 favorites at
home bill which way you lean in here you
know I didn't see a second of that
Steelers game I don't know what how was
Big Ben looking he looked pretty like
typical Road Big Ben like through five
with five interceptions yeah five
interceptions I'm turnovers maybe hey no
I think he I think he threw maybe four
or five picks they had six turnovers
overall but he didn't look good at all I
like the Steelers at home I don't like
that number though he's picked a perfect
you know the Chiefs are the Chiefs yes
the Chiefs you know I me until they're
not the Chiefs to the Chiefs the
Steelers are still the Steelers I like
historical betting at this point well
and I think you know talk about
overreaction oh my god Big Ben was
horrible he's always bad on the road oh
my god they actually in a tighter they
tied the Browns Le'Veon Bell is not the
Big Ben he's old-school that guy he's
just you know and he gets it done in the
big moments of the games and in it I
don't know III I believe in that guy
still yeah he looks like he plays well
on the home at home and that's why I
like this like we're gonna fade public
perception but the Steelers stink and
we're gonna fade public perception that
the Chiefs are gonna win the Super Bowl
because oh my god Andy Reid started well
again I mean look this is a classic fade
recency this line opened at 7 shun and
people have been crushing the Chiefs
side of this so let the number come down
I'm also going to be on the Steelers
Shaun I think this is a great kind of
fade recency both ways here Wow
it's gonna be a clean sweep all right
all in agreeance on all these picks I
love the Steelers at home coming off
eight I mean not a loss but it may as
well be then you come home for their
home opener you know they're gonna
bounce back and I mean while you got the
Chiefs coming off a huge road victory to
go to the other side of the country in
Pittsburgh mahomes smelling himself like
come on yeah and we watched that we
watched that game Ryan the Chiefs
secondary looked horrible like I was I
was factoring in the them going out to
LA then to Kansas City then out to
Pittsburgh but yeah they're gonna next
they're gonna be dehydrated from all
those salty peanuts I just I just think
it's a good spot for Pittsburgh at home
home opener
yeah the city defense is just they're
passing defense in particulars just
horrible and it's a passing league I I
just feel like Pittsburgh is gonna be
able to throw all over them any can you
say with confidence that they're passing
these stinks I'm not giving you crap
here sure just after one week well I'll
give you two reasons one reason is I
watched the game and I saw that the
Chargers receivers were wide open a
number of times it just dropped easy
catchable balls and then - other than
that other than that my other mother
deeper reason is I sit next to a Chiefs
fan at work and every day he opens up
his laptop and starts reading blogs and
just goes our [__] secondary [__]
sucks so I'm kind of using that as well
one you over all right build you what
you know wrap things up here you hit
with your lock last week you were two
and one with your
the lock of course was that the sky was
falling down or that the the announcer's
but all proclaimed the sky was falling
down yes hopefully we get that three I
know this week but what's your what's
your lock prediction for NFL week to one
person tweets that women should not be
play-by-play announcers and by Wednesday
gonna say something oh yeah somebody
will say something and then it's gonna
become this huge thing then I think by
this time next year all play-by-play
people will be women that would be
that's that that is my luck block it up
Doris Burke will be doing every day as a
joke I was joking with my buddy going I
go dude Burt Reynolds died in the
play-by-play on Monday Night Football is
the female I go it really is over we had
so as a joke I actually looked up the
Elks Club going like I'm gonna just see
what the Elks Club that's in men's club
or whatever hooked it up and in 2005
first of all I looked it up and the
picture was of a woman when you go to
the website they sued in 2005 and one so
like even they've even infiltrated
obviously the arguably the biggest group
of jerk-off men in the country I mean
you Lilly talk I don't think way like
the hats with the little tassel you see
yeah it's hilarious like I looked it up
I would never join it but I was just I
just it was gonna get a kick out of the
fact that there was one place left where
you could just chill out and not have to
adjust your behavior
it was the Elks Club in Augusta National
and then both those have been
infiltrated they are now no longer
all-male all right yeah man really did
have a hell of a run hey all every
dynasty must come to an end
tens of thousands of years triplets yeah
we weren't a three-headed monster for a
long time well this is a lot of people
are saying this is a rebuilding year for
men you know we're hoping to get the
number one draft pick to
a lot of heat lost a lot of lost a lotta
took a lot of elves out there yeah we're
gonna try to forget about last year and
uh you know we're gonna hit reset
we got Jon Gruden back so much Jon
Gruden face I can't wait man it was he
was he was just kind of a different guy
in the broadcast booth Ben there's a
second he put though that headphones
back on again he just want to play back
to the Chucky face I loved it yeah the
thing that was frustrating about him as
an announcer was that clearly he thought
about getting back into coaching so he
wouldn't badmouth guys on the air and he
just loved everyone is he great guys
look at this guy and then as soon as
he's got that headset on you could just
see him screaming and yelling he was he
was just so pissed a car alright I'm
gonna get more bold with my predictions
is once you know I hopefully you know
what am I actually my shows got moved
this weekend because of that hurricane
which hopefully goes out to sea my
supposed to work in Virginia in South
Carolina so I'm hoping that you know you
know a lot of those people are probably
still upside down in their houses
because the piece-of-shit bankers so the
last thing they need is a hurricane to
hit the house it's gonna be worth more
than what they owe on it screwed by the
insurance companies as well yes
yeah for the trifecta so I'm that's what
I'm thinking about this week I'm
supposed to be there to follow me but I
but the other side was I will be home
and have enough time to watch the game
so hopefully silver lining and a shout
out to Dakota Prescott love it alright
and obviously check out bill burr comm
for all the upcoming tour information
and of course check out my book ejg
promo code phil bets for that hundred
percent deposit bonus play win and get
paid my bookie dad AG
[Music]
Oh
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it is the Monday morning podcast for
Monday September 13 2010 what's going on
how are you you feeling good I'm gonna
try to pretend like I am I actually went
out drinking last night and a little
banged up a little banged up it's
actually 1001 East Coast time I'm in New
York City this is uh the biggest week of
the year for me I'm back here doing
press for my new one-hour special let it
go that comes out and premieres they
switch the date on me it is now it's
Sunday September 19th at 11 p.m. so
please tune in please listen please
watch please invite other people over
why don't you have a little [__]
stand-up comedy party don't they have
those they have Super Bowl parties you
know we invite a bunch of broads over
and they talk during the game and they
shut up during the commercials I kind of
like that one how much do you think that
that one cost it it it anyways yes I'm
in town this week I'm gonna be doing the
Opie and Anthony program my [__]
favorite I'm gonna be doing that I
believe I'm gonna be doing something on
the vs. Network I'm going to be talking
to anybody with the microphone this week
doing my gosh darndest to try and get
people to listen to my [__] podcast
but uh how many podcast see what happens
when I multitask to get people to watch
my special and I'm gonna apologize for
the lack of funny up until this point
already right out of the [__] gate
just because I have to make sure I get
this information out at the beginning of
the podcast all right so my special
September 19th at 11 p.m. on Comedy
Central please go ahead and watch it and
if you want to preorder my DVD look into
your heart
if you want to order this thing for an
unbelievably ridiculously almost an
embarrassingly low price you can order
the
[__] thing for like $13 in like 29
cents on amazon.com I don't know how the
[__] they came up with that price but I
got to admit I felt a little insulted
you know why don't you just [__] give
it away amazon.com so there you go
why don't you buy - look at that that's
right after that's gonna be $19.99 so
then if you actually go out and buy -
then if you come out to my show you'll
be like dude stop bitching about your
free [__] podcast because I actually
bought two your DVDs and I'll be
thinking in my head wow this guy dropped
40 bucks what a good [__] and you'll be
laughing cuz in the back of your head
you like actually I dropped 26 and
change you know 26 and change I mean
what can you what can you get two of for
$26 I can get gum get two packs of gum
actually probably a lot more than that
of course if we go to Foot Locker those
[__] t-shirts you can get like one
what can you get like like 58 t-shirts
at Foot Locker is that Michael Moore's
next movie if I was Michael Moore and I
was going what the [__] sure that in the
next movie should I make about how poor
people are sad and rich people are evil
I would try and find who are the people
who mail who are these people they make
the [__]
you know how do they give you [__]
like ninety shirts for $18 how do they
do that
you know what this I'm not even hung
over but I just I rather than being hung
over which I should have been but I
wasn't but I'm not whatever I'm trying
to say I just woke up with just weird
music in my head you ever do that you
wake up you drank last night you not
hungover but you just wake up and then
you're just singing some song that you
haven't even thought of for years I was
just walking around my my [__]
apartment here just walking around going
some like it hot some like it hot bump
bump bump bump bump pop up about ba bap
and then how it goes feel the heat
burning into
knife of the night whatever the [__] it
is is that Robert Palmer something like
it hot ooh
Robert Palmer tell us about your new
sexy sultry single with that hot Latino
beat underneath it well I had recently
gone to Cuba and I inserted a [__]
Cohiba into some [__] prostitutes
orifice and I was just really
overwhelmed by the culture down there
don't you [__] hate that you know and
me whenever like the white star tries to
have some sort of ethnic beat under
their music and then they always got to
talk about some trip that they took to
Swahili and how when they were sitting
there in that Walden Resort they somehow
[__] absorb the culture you know you
guys haven't gone down to the Caribbean
you gone down to the Caribbean however
the [__] you say it some people say
Caribbean some people say Caribbean but
to me it's it's all one beautiful
universes you guys went down the
Caribbean to go scuba diving to be
nose-to-nose with a [__] barracuda
they get barracudas down there quick why
don't you look it up and then send me an
email and tell me how [__] uninformed
I am actually barracuda or did you do
this eagle for Brazil shut the [__] up
I can look this [__] up too what is it a
freshwater fish if you go down to like
[__] Uruguay can you get a barracuda
sandwich you know just to start your day
rather than getting like a bacon egg and
cheese do they do that and do they use
the whole fish because they're better
than Americans where we would just like
use like just the best part of the fish
and then the rest we would just sort of
throw out the window just toss it back
into the ocean and it gets all hooked up
with like old rollerblades and [__]
those shoes every guy wore in the late
90s remember those [__] shoes so
slip-on shoes that sort of look like
sneakers kind of look like shoes
remember those [__] things where are
all those right now huh
I'll tell you where they are they're
floating out in the middle of the
Pacific Ocean
getting broken down on the sunlight
right and then some dolphin inhales it
and then you go out to Japan right
and they don't give a [__] about
dolphins you guys see the cove you know
the [__] dolphin Schindler's List
basically I couldn't I just heard what
that movie was about and I [__] love
animals so much that I couldn't I
couldn't even know Schindler's List
actually had somebody [__] decent in
it trying to help out those being
slaughtered how what the [__] am i I
didn't even see the goddamn movie all I
heard was a bunch of people they drive
these dolphins into this [__] Cove
and then they just beat him to death and
it was it was so fun just to hear it was
so [__] sad and then it just made me
so goddamn angry that I was like you
know what I'm not gonna [__] I'm not
gonna you know I'm not gonna watch that
stuff cuz what am I gonna do uh-oh who
got himself the treat at the local deli
this is well this is how you get out of
shape in New York even though you walk
around all the time is you just walk
into a deli and you're like you know
what I'm gonna start my day we're on our
way to the perfect place the perfect
place pump up uh but up up but up up
that's another [__] song just popped
in my head what is that from hey it's
the perfect place was that that was like
a hanna-barbera cartoon we're on our way
to the perfect place the perfect place
anyways I'm sorry this is like some I
have weird hangover sometimes I don't
have a headache I just just music pops
into my head some like it hot anyways
some white guy playing yoga blocks does
that sound Latino speaking of Latino I
went into one of these little [__]
bodegas la la hija Lai donde as the
[__] orange juice uh um I was up
there and I got myself a no J and a
banana because I'm really into these
like breakfast --is now I finally
realized that when you wake up and you
have a lumberjack breakfast that
seriously it's like I've been saying on
this podcast it's like getting up it's
like if you just woke up the second you
woke up and you just sprinted 400 yards
without stretching or anything didn't
even put on your [__] shoes you just
ran down the street on the [__]
pebbles right that's what you're doing
to your body that's why I start slow I
get a little [__] corn-based orange
juice according to Food Inc it's all
corn now excuse me and then I have a
banana you know which is like sort of
like baby food in a phallic form it's
what it's like it's like a big [__]
would have a big yellow dick what animal
like a [__] porno star canary if you
want a deaf that's what a bananas like
right so typical New York I'm trying to
eat healthy and then I look over and I
see these two little toasted balls to
add to the [__] the the canary thing
right like they lopped off his [__]
Porto nuts and I looked at the lady and
I was like hola senorita what the [__]
are those and she's like all those those
are coconut balls and I was like get the
[__] out of here
and she says I can't get the [__] out of
here I have to work and I said nah I
didn't mean it literally I meant get the
[__] out of here
those are made out of coconut and she
said see and I was like I [__] love
coconut you know and she started
laughing like I never said you didn't
[__] oh do you want him and I'm like
absolutely I want him so now I have him
so after telling you guys I was going to
begin my day with you know eating really
healthy I ended up grabbing two sugar
balls actually they called I actually
hear the Coco Komeito
and underneath an English macaroon
coconut here's the ingredients sugar
coconut and then in parenthesis says may
contain sodium metaphor hush hush hush
hush for whiteness I love that [__] like
how much did they do not even research
what the [__] is yeah I mean might might
might have a little bit of this
met up by sulphite for whiteness
well the coconuts white why would you
need to add to that is this some coconut
that you [__] head in a warehouse for
years egg whites invert sugar corn syrup
and salt so for the most part it's all
natural except for the sodium
metabisulfite I'd select for whiteness
and I'm gonna try one let's see
sweet dreams are made of these how bad
is [__] Annie Lennox when you think
of the annals of the [__] baddest
Rock chicks
we'll start with white chicks right
we'll move all the way around we'll
start with the baddest white chicks of
all time I would say [__] Annie
Lennox and no particular order here if I
was Rolling Stone I do an entire issue
of this the hundreds greatest rock
chicks of all time Rolling Stone really
is clearly showing people if you haven't
been paying attention how few people
buying magazines now Oh disgusting it's
like a doughnut
eyes gross that's too much that's
[__] disgusting I have to take
another bite because now my sugar
starting to rise right now I'm craving
another hit man oh yeah I stand
corrected these are [__] delicious
see the first bite here's your body
going no don't do it so it tastes like
[__]
but then that sugar gets in your veins
and it's like come on man you know you
want it then you just keep going
alright this is really rude to be eating
on the mic alright Annie Lennox you know
and then I can't even think now Ernie
Lennox the chick from the pretenders
Chrissie Hynde right
Pat Benatar now that's not what I wanted
I you know I always got to confuse with
the chick from The Runaways Joan Jett
Joan Jett says [__] um and she's still
hot
god dammit those are [__] delicious
ah not after a swig of OJ de ros okay
they're really hard to chew ah one of my
[__] neighbors just here just heard
that wondering what the [__] I'm talking
about
um all right sorry sorry you know what
I'm actually last night
no finish your [__] thought bill if
you look at Rolling Stone they used to
be this big magazine just I'm talking
about when you held it it was used to be
like a [__] third bigger now they've
shrunk it down to it's like a third of
the size it used to be and now every
other month they're doing those those
list things
100 greatest guitarists of all time 100
greatest tambourine players of all time
right now they have the hundred greatest
Beatles songs of all time it's like ours
did they even write a hundred songs you
know they just do that so people can you
know they I guess people always buy
those magazines and they go what the
[__] how could you put hey bulldog in
front of well my guitar gently weeps and
then people write notes was that really
worth revisiting I don't think it was
well those are my top three top three
[__] white chick rock singers of all
time and well considering we've been
talking so much about Latinos let's go
with top three Latinos of all time
Latinos singers and this is when my
whiteness is gonna come out to see if I
can even name three Selena they did a
movie about her
Selena Jennifer Lopez and [__] this is
embarrassing
uh Lucille Ball and Lucille Ball [__]
you she was married to Ricky Ricardo BAM
those year three but she never really
sang did you what the [__] I know I know
more than that Selena I don't even know
any songs Selena sang I just know she
had a psycho fan that's all I know and
then Jennifer Lopez played her oh wait
wait the chick from Miami Sound Machine
right what songs did they sing ooh Miami
we're [__] taking over what songs did
they sing I saw that [__] band stunk
Miami Sound Machine all that [__]
turquoise well all that that just when I
pictured them I just was a bunch of
people in puffy pants and they had like
58 people on percussion and then like
one keyboard and then she was skipping
around in her boots right isn't that
wasn't what Miami style machine was the
[__] songs do they sing god dammit I
used to know all of this [__] I can't
get that Robert Palmer [__] out of my
head anyways whatever so I want to learn
something
tell me give me your top three Latino
[__] singers of all time I know
somebody's already compiling a list and
getting pissed at me because I don't
know what the [__] I'm talking about but
that's what people do in this podcast
like last week I made uh I made a
reference to the Pullman Strike when I
was reading about Grover Cleveland or
some [__] like that and this guy wrote
he wrote hey uninformed bill the reason
they brought the military in during the
Pullman Strike was because the workers
in quotes he puts were becoming violent
not because they were striking because
they were attacking the alternate
workers brought in to fill the void of
Labor caused by the strike this is
hilarious the guy writes down his name
marketing and business development
coordinator yeah you sound like the guy
who would side with the [__] people
who who are under paying its first of
all why do you put workers in in
parentheses
you know what I mean the strike was
because the workers were becoming
violent
not because they were striking because
they were attacking the scabs they
brought in to take their jobs that's
part of a strike you dumb [__] you know
you know I love to sir is the way you're
acting as though you had even heard of
the Pullman Strike before I said it
that's that classic internet [__] we
don't have to go to the library anymore
you just look up the Pullman Strike and
then you read two paragraphs and you're
like oh actually you know what the
reason is you're just as dumb as me sir
of course they attack the scab workers
brought in because now they're gonna be
out of out of a job and that was my
point and who does the military side
with the military works for the [__]
rich people all right if you don't
[__] believe that then I'm not gonna
eat another [__] coconut ball
oh it just gets better no it doesn't
alright that's enough of that Jesus
Christ Jesus all right let's talk NFL
football everybody oh but before I do
the mmm podcast calm everybody I made a
video on there where I did a little tour
of the Comedy Store and I also stood
outside the Comedy Store and I talked
[__] about some of the people walking by
and down the street if you guys want to
check it out go to the mmm podcast com
um the official the one and only the
only one there is the official fan page
of the Monday morning podcast and I also
want to thank everybody who went out and
bought the og
ringtone last week all right I was very
impressed with the amount of people that
uh that went ahead and bought the
ringtone if you didn't listen last week
I have a new ringtone it all costs it's
99 cents and you know that way I don't
have to really charge for the [__]
podcast and it's also a it's not
required if you want to do it you can if
you don't you don't it's no big deal and
we have all the instructions up there if
you have an iPhone it goes right out to
your phone if you have a blackberry
there's like one one little thing you
have to do or something but they have
all the instructions
on the mmm podcast on how to upload it
to your phone and you know we just want
to thank everybody for being patient if
a couple took a couple days to explain
it to get the information out there so I
wanted to thank you guys but shipping
and seriously means a lot to me that
people actually went out and supported
the podcast like that so thank you from
the bottom of my heart and the gentleman
who runs the MM podcast com
all right and with that bump up Bob boto
bowed out it's time to talk about NFL
football here
I actually was flying on a plane during
the Patriots game so I can't really talk
too much about it
other than that I just I was watching I
actually had satellite TV on on the on
the plane so I was sitting there gonna
[__] I'm gonna miss the [__] game and
then I see that they're gonna have
satellite TV and I got excited oh boy oh
boy
right and I [__] turn it on and all I
get I had NBC and then the rest were
like Discovery Animal Planet and then
they had three ESPN's so I'm praying how
I hope and pray that I will but today I
am still just a bail [__] you these
songs are in my head because I'm
hungover um praying that the Patriots
game was gonna be on NBC and it turned
out that not only was the game not on
NBC
they didn't even have a football game on
NBC they had some [__] infomercial on
insults so I was like you gotta be
[__] kidding me
right you gotta be [__] kidding me
and so then I just was watching ESPN I
was watching all the college football
games that I already watched I think
Michigan's back everybody hail to the
victors valiant hail to the victor the
pepper pepper pepper pepper pepper
pepper pepper pepper pepper see what I
just did there I did three [__]
college songs and they all sound the
exact [__] same hail to the victors
wake up the echoes and [__] the
Fleetwood Mac Trojan band
it's all the same [__] anyways yes I
watch that I watch the
the USA basketball game against Turkey
that was the [__] and we won that
championship but anyways I was watching
the ticker and by the way
what's-his-face there is gonna be the
next superstar and I saw him when he
played in Seattle and I can t remember
his [__] name already
cuz I'm that [__] hungover come on
brain work for me
begins with a D I can't [__] remember
but he was a [__] he was hitting fall
away three-pointers as a 6:10 I'm in
what position he but I don't know I
don't know [__] about basketball
alright let's plow ahead here um
Patriots one the Colts lost so I'm
excited right
I'm so excited how about Detroit how
about Cleveland come on you guys you got
to admit you know you had a little bit
uh I think I think there does this a ray
of light I didn't see any either one of
those [__] games but I was just I was
just watching the ticker and I saw that
that dude from playful Cal best had two
touchdowns right and Cleveland was
basically one in the [__] game right
down to the end I know I'm not trying to
talk down to you guys but I'm just
saying and you know whatever you beat
Miami that's got to feel good look you
know what the main reason why I'm
bringing this [__] up is is because I
want to say this [__] before the [__]
game comes out tonight I got 50 bucks on
the Ravens tonight straight-up I bet it
straight up even though the Jets are
favored by like six I don't know what
the line is but I was like you know what
you can keep your [__] points there
Missy I don't give a [__] that's how
confident I am how [__] dumb are the
New York Jets
what are they can you just can somebody
explain to me the strategy of pissing
off every [__] every team in the
league
it's first of all I love it being a
Patriots fan because for the first time
in ten [__] years nobody was talking
about Bill Belichick nobody was talking
about the Patriots nobody was talking
about Tom Brady really think I even got
into a [__] car accident and that was
barely a [__] story compared to to
the
shitstorm that is going on with the New
York Jets what what are they doing let
me ask you guys a question how amped up
does Ray Lewis get before a football
game when when the other team hasn't
talked [__] about him are they they're
out of their [__] minds Ray Lewis I
put it on my facebook page that's my
prediction he is gonna rip Sanchez's
[__] head off tonight
Sanchez this guy who everybody for some
reason they're forgetting the up and
down season that he had last year and
they're they're acting like they have
this proven quarterback I don't get it
man
and they went out and they drafted all
think they got to sign all these free
agents they're really reminded me of the
University of Miami when they got off
the plane wearing the fatigues and they
were talking all this [__] and then when
it came down to it they didn't [__]
win anything remember that oh like the
Los Angeles Lakers when they added Gary
Payton and Carl Malone and you're
thinking how can they not [__] and
and they didn't I don't I don't get it
that that year when the Patriots went
undefeated in the regular season and
then got their asses kicked in in the
Super Bowl by the Giants it's like the
hype was so [__] big that from
November on we were playing playoff
games teams were coming in so [__]
amped up to kick the [__] out of us
it just wore it it wore us down it wors
down to me while no one's paying
attention to the Giants to the point
that Giants put up like 35 points and
the last week of the season against us
and for some reason we were still 14
point favorites three [__] weeks
later to this day I kick myself for not
taking that bet and yeah it was
ridiculous I mean while a giant said
beating Tampa Bay and Tampa Bay they
beat Dallas and Dallas they beat Green
Bay and Green Bay and no one's paying
attention to him then everybody sat
there with that jaws in the ground they
kicked this didn't even kick the [__]
out of us they just beat us like holy
[__] how did this team that beat three
awesome teams in their own [__]
building come in and beat us yeah it's
[__] ridiculous
so the Jets have started their season at
zero and zero with the whole league as
amped up to kick the [__] out of them as
people were amped up to beat the [__]
Patriots
it by mid-november all right and I'm
telling you right now they are gonna
have a mediocre [__] season I think
it's gonna start off with the loss
tonight I'm not saying that they're not
gonna go 9 and 7 but these guys I don't
know what the [__] problem is and not
to mention that now they have a nice
little scandal here cover The Daily News
they says cool your jets
TV reporter Flags team for lewd behavior
enas Saints reporter for Azteca TV where
the [__] is that broadcast it's is at
the center of a jet brouhaha basically
if you see this girl she's [__] hottie
right she's got her little pass here and
uh you know she's got some cleavage show
oh my god are you serious they got a
picture of her at a Jets practice she's
got on the tightest [__] jeans I've
ever seen in my life with the most
perfect round ass you've ever seen and
she's in high heels okay and she's
walking around a bunch of football
players who got that testosterone going
with a fetch [__] talking coach let me
guess
somebody said something out of line this
is just this is you know what I mean
this right here and this is one of these
things well you can't say well look how
you dressed cuz they go you're blaming
the victim she should have a right to
have 3/4 of her tit outside of her shirt
with a thong going up her [__] ass
crack and she should be allowed to walk
into a locker room with a bunch of
football players and not have one out of
[__] whatever the [__] you're gonna
say well one [__] rude comment give
me a break
NFL boss Roger Goodell was demanding
answers last night from Jets players
well once you look at the pictures Roger
huh what are you a [__] eunuch you
don't understand what the problem was
for players coaches accused of
subjecting a female sports reporter to
sexist locker room conduct they should
have just said for subjecting her to
locker room conduct this is basically
what happened
she went into a locker room and was
subjected to locker room conduct can you
believe it I remember last night when I
went out to a bar and I was subjected to
barroom conduct I couldn't believe it I
was like what am i in a bar or something
as they prepare for their season opener
tonight gangrene is dealing with a
burgeoning scandal over the treatment of
in as Saints for Aztecas of Mexico this
girl is a 10 she's [__] smoking
gorgeous up Amy you got to see the way
she's dressed okay
and [__] you ladies [__] you look at the
way she's dressed she's one of those you
know it's funny about the Broads out
there is this is the kind of girl all
right the kind of woman the kind of
[__] whoo whoo if you know if any of
these women you know well listen his
podcast they're walking down the street
with their husband and this girl comes
walking by they immediately they dig
[__] you know that eyes become like
little slits as they look enemy you know
and then they're looking at their
husband and they're gonna get mad at you
because this other [__] goes to the gym
you know like somehow it's your [__]
fault and they [__] looking at you
because they can't just come out and say
oh my god that girl is [__] gorgeous
I'm so jealous of her they can't they
can't own that emotion so then they look
at you and they're just waiting for you
to glance in that pert and that woman's
direction so they can blame you that
this [__] another girl is eating right
and and [__] doing herself up right
it's gonna become your [__] fault I
used to do a bit about that next time
you know it tears one for you gonna burn
a joke right here that I never [__]
recorded so who gives a [__] next time
you're walking down the street with your
girlfriend right and this [__]
unbelievably smoking chick comes walking
up the street right and what do you got
and she immediately just looks at you
like go ahead and look at her so I can
take out my [__] hatred of this
better-looking girl and make it your
[__] fault right this is what you do
rather than trying to look away and
having blood come out of your out of
your eyes you try not to look at this
[__] hot piece of hair coming up the
street what you do is you [__] point
right at her and whatever she's wearing
you tell your girl that she'd look great
in that you point rather be like you
know you'd look great in a dress like
that right
and then immediately just a peek you
know it makes entrance security go oh my
god really do you think I could get away
with me something bad totally you just
girls failing good
you're staring at the girl's ass you're
talking about the cut of the dress it's
[__] you're checking around without
disrespecting your woman see right there
bill burr bringing couples together all
right let's continue on here so this
woman 32 years old 32 years old still in
smoke and [__] shape a former Miss
Universe contestant complained she was
bombarded with catcalls and boorish
antics at the Jets New Jersey training
facility to the extent she wanted to and
in quotes that cover my ears I'm dying
of embarrassment this woman right former
Miss Universe contestant who would walk
on stage with a [__] string bikini
and high heels with a hoo-ha hanging out
talking about how to save Greenland or
whatever is embarrassed cuz she walked
or at me give me a few know what I mean
this is why women stink it's like what
are you doing there
to begin with it's a bunch of guys
playing football it's like and then
we're cool enough to let you in there
and then everybody has to [__] adjust
their behavior because you're there wait
excuse me excuse me there's a lady
present
you know what I mean and you wonder why
you get called a [__] that's why right
[__] there it's just [__]
unbelievable I would never walk into a
goddamn baby shower be oh excuse me
excuse me there's a guy president can we
put a [__] game on over here I
wouldn't I'd be standing in the corner
gone uh oh jeez when is this [__] gonna
be over but I wouldn't at any point try
to cock-block what anybody was [__]
talking about go ahead and talk about
sex in the city talk about your favorite
shoes or whatever the [__] it is you do
I wouldn't be covering my ears dying of
embarrassment if you all started talking
about my package I'd be flattered
um this is some of the more ignorant
[__] that I've said on this podcast but
I think there's a point behind this
let's continue with the article Goodell
is she said I'm dying of embarrassment
Saints tweeted in Spanish Goodell
immediately ordered an investigation
into the troubling in air quotes
allegations which were addressed in a
team meeting last night this meeting is
now called to order last night when that
smokin hot chick with the tight clothes
came in and everybody said god damn look
at that [__] ass yeah you're not
allowed to do that anymore excuse me
coach yeah yes sir yeah we're you
talking about that girl who came in or a
titties were hanging out of his shirt
yeah that one yeah that one
we disrespected her see this is this is
the deal all right
they come down they want the [__]
attention you know what wait what what
is she what is she doing in the [__]
locker room to begin with you know what
she even in the locker room did I even
say that I can't remember
didn't you see any given Sunday you know
remember that movie you're gonna stand
there and there's gonna be some black
dude with a dick down to the floor I
mean why are you going and I wouldn't go
in there if I went in there they'd start
giving me cat calls like I was that
fresh fish guy in the beginning of
Shawshank Redemption and I'd be dying of
embarrassment too but I'd [__] take
it and be like yeah well what the [__]
did you think was gonna happen
you're a [__] pansy and you come
walking into an NFL locker room they're
all gonna give you [__] and say you're a
[__] right I mean what kind of a
[__] world are we living in now when
a gorgeous woman wearing tight
ridiculous clothes is gonna walk into a
[__] at a football practice and she's
gonna get upset that said that she got
unwanted attention well why don't you
come there and dress like they did in
the 1800s with one of them big hoop
skirts so they can't see your [__]
thighs this chick is [__] ridiculous
look look at the New York The Daily News
and look at the little
said picture that they have of her I'm
sure they did it for a [__] reason
it's ridiculous
look at that [__] ass look at that's
the first thing I think look at that
[__] ass
Jesus Christ and then she's holding a
mic looks like a dick in her hand
was she bobbing her head up and down as
she asked the questions this is like
entrapment
anyways let's [__] continue um we've
had contact with the team multiple times
and are moving very aggressively to
establish the facts the NFL spokesman
Greg Aiello said Jets owner Woody
Johnson woke up from his coma and said
oh wait that guy no no that guy's
actually young called Saints to hear her
side of the story and said that that the
team will take any appropriate steps
necessary to maintain a respectful
environment for the media basically this
girl is now gonna become a [__]
millionaire off of this lawsuit because
she walked to an NFL practice with her
Miss Universe body with tight [__]
clothes on and somebody said god damn
look at that [__] ass right there hey
Mark what the [__] would you do with
that ID I'd [__] bend her over [__]
table and then [__] Rex Ryan I can't
even see her my [__] my [__]
stomach so big huh was that a good one
players do you guys like me I talk just
like you I can't wait for them to
[__] lose tonight they're gonna get
their [__] asses kicked they can't
get their asses kicked but they're gonna
lose they're gonna lose and then they're
gonna have a short week all right
and guess who's back the New England
Patriots huh
thirty-eight [__] points up against
Oh Joe Cinco Terrell Owens Cade McNown
what's the name of your quarterback
something Wilson I don't even know the
name of your [__] quarterback he was
awesome and then he got hurt he's
actually a good quarterback what the
[__] his name I know it's not cable
now UCLA [__] Iseman Trophy winner
classic Chicago Bear quarterback Drock
draft they love Cade McNown they love
the rex grossman for some reason they
didn't like Doug Flutie let's get let's
ship him out of there really you want to
ship a proven winner out absolutely we
don't want him around here
leading the team to victories where the
[__] is a goddamn Patriots game here Oh
Carson Palmer this is what I love about
that man he was 34 454 345 yards Oh Cho
Cinco had 12 catches for 159 yards all
right
yet they only scored 24 [__] points
you know my buddy was saying that
they're getting back to that bend but
don't break you know someone else was
telling me Belichick is doing the
defense again which is his [__]
that's that's what he does I don't know
I have I have high hopes but you know
it's not about the Patriots this year
it's all about the J et s Jets Jets Jets
right running their [__] yaps you
wanted the attention now you got it ah I
can't [__] wait you guys looked up
the stats of that [__] Joe Flacco a
Joe Falco whatever the [__] his name is
I don't know what his name is all I know
is they raped us last year in the
playoffs you got Ray Rice is gonna be
running all over you [__] [__] huh
what do you think cuz you got that old
guy from the Dolphins that good-looking
son of a [__] you should be doing
[__] underwear ads like Jim Palmer
that's the guy that's the guy that's
gonna stop everybody that dude has been
showing up late to practice and Rex Ryan
is making a joke out of it because he
has such a [__] need to be liked by
his own goddamn players you wait you
wait to the [__] wheels fall off
alright here's a contest I want I want
to introduce here how about whoever
guesses which week Rex Ryan's gonna
[__] cry first
after which game if you pick it right
I'm gonna send you an autographed copy
of my new [__] DVD so there you go
people you got [__] 17 weeks to pick
one actually not this week 16 weeks I'm
including the by week the first week
he's gonna start [__] crying because
somebody criticized him you know a
somebody stole his M&M flavored [__]
ice cream all right enough of this [__]
that's my thing I got 50 bucks 50 bucks
on the Ravens and I'm confident I'm
confident that not only I don't even
take to spread straight-up can you tell
I don't know what else to talk about I
just keep saying over and over
my bet is let's talk about depression
shall we speaking of [__] Rex Ryan
somebody sent me a long email here that
should eat up some time actually did I
tell you guys last night we actually
recorded me and DeRosa got [__]
hammered last night and we like you know
what we should do we should go home and
record a drunk uninformed I'm like well
I have to do the Monday morning podcast
he goes we'll [__] do that too so
last night for an hour and a half as we
sat there drinking and getting even more
drunk drunk er er whatever the [__]
word is we recorded we talked for at
least an hour and a half the recorders
shut off at an hour and 15 [__]
minutes and you just hear us get
progressively more and more drunk I
listen to it there's a lot of funny
moments but it's just way too long so I
am gonna I'm gonna edit it I'm gonna
dice it up and I'll put together a
greatest hits of it do you got that
coming up but I just it was just too
much self-sabotage it's like I got my
special coming out this week I really
had to make sure I hyped it and I
completely was not hyping it in a great
way you know which I thought it was bad
it was bad and there was a lot of
embarrassing moments and you know I you
know I'm just I'm gonna edit it people
that's what I'm trying to say all right
go [__] yourselves I'm not putting it
all up alright YouTube videos of the
week fat kid goes insane after getting
air horned in the face try to guess what
that one's about fat kid goes insane
after getting airhorn airhorn in the
face and this kid face he looks like if
if precious was a white eight-year-old
just picture that face that's what this
kid looks like all right here's what I'm
sure everybody saw says face verse
watermelon this is somebody on The
Amazing Race that took a slingshot and
and shot a watermelon or a [__]
cantaloupe I don't know what it was and
it came back and blasts her right in the
face it's absolutely hilarious
they actually showed it on ESPN they did
the top 10 funny sports moments of the
weekend hers was number one and you know
what they did because she's abroad what
they had to do was they put you know you
know when they had the list of
that they're gonna talk about coming up
on the right-hand part of the screen out
of nowhere right before the cantaloupe
or watermelon blaster in the face they
put that up and half censor their head
because I can guarantee you there was
some woman there going this is gonna
just it's gonna cause violence against
women how is it gonna cause violence
against women because the way the
watermelon just slaps her in the face is
just it was self-inflicted that's one of
those things once again those double
standard if a guy did that do you think
they'd censor it what if it came back
and hit him in his nuts and he actually
lost the ability to have a child they
still would have shown that completely
uncensored wait a minute is this a
special guest who just walked in Joe I
got lucky I got another eight minutes
just sit down and help me through it Wow
don't be a [__] get over here pick up the
microphone ladies and gentlemen look who
just walked in hey folks Joe DeRosa oh
yeah Jesus Christ Joe what are you doing
here I you know I was just walking
through the studio bill and I saw you
through the glass this is like that
moment went [__] Johnny Carson walked
over to uh what's his face his sitcom
when he was doing cpoe Sharky remember
that when he broke his uh what's his
name
Dom DeLuise Don Rickles yeah he just
came walking in this is very old school
yeah I just actually alluded to them not
even alluded I mentioned that we did a
podcast I finally doc how we did a
podcast last night completely [__]
shit-faced and uh
of the hour and 14 minutes how much do
you think is gonna be funny that we can
actually chop up I think at least four
minutes of it was really good I think
the bulk of it was funny which I made a
good point about like it's just a little
too much all at once like you gotta
split it up a little yeah and it just
kept meandering and then by the end I
was just I was really getting into your
financial businesses of some deal that
you had and we were like yeah we don't
we don't want that on there yeah let me
tell you about the cuts and that's
business Joe it was really sloppy but
dude I got tell you were [__]
hilarious on it you - I loved it I was
little I was I was kind of an angry
that's that whiskey [__] to bear I'm a
happy drunk you know don't blow
don't blame the whiskey bill huh no no
I'm already angry but like I see I want
to [__] it when I'm sober I keep I keep
it in check for the most part for the
most part but when I drink whiskey then
I'm not if I drink beer you know I got
my arm around people and we'll all go
down together they're all singing songs
right
I'm good time Charlie with the beer I
start drinking whiskey oh it's awful do
can you finish chewing whatever is in
your mouth it's a fingernail is biting
my nails ah spit out y'all let me to get
over your [__] all right
yeah what do you want me to do I want
you to [__] it I'll see what happens
why yeah yeah be a professional you know
yeah Joe you look at this you know I was
just and I just went off on this can you
see this woman here she walks she showed
up at a NFL practice this former Miss
Universe here look at she dressed at the
practice whoo yeah looking good she's
hot yeah and guess and evidently
somebody made some people who made she
was subjected to catcalling Joe can you
imagine that you could look like that
dress like that and you can't go to an
NFL practice without getting cash so she
upset about it upset she tweeted in
Spanish that she was I'm dying of
embarrassment she had to cover her ears
well look I gotta say though she looks
great but she is wearing jeans and a
shirt it's like what the hell she's
supposed to wear something she's in a
miniskirt out Joe she's wearing high
heels look at a joke how tight of those
goddamn jeans ah righteously tie really
John what would you do with that Joe Oh
bill tell me [__] leave it in
disappointment
look I'm not look I'm not condoning that
you shouldn't you shouldn't do that
hey she was asking for it I'm not she
was no what the hell she's supposed to
wear what she supposed to wear sweat
pants Joe is it possible for those jeans
to get any tighter no but that's how
chicks wear their jeans chicks don't
wear baggy jeans they wear tight jeans
you know something Joe why don't you
just walk back out the door and bring in
the [__] Joe DeRosa that I know all
right all right she's a whoo
I'm kidding what Joe if I walk through
Central Park at 3:00 in the [__]
morning dressed like Liberace singing
I'm in the money and I get the [__]
kicked out of me and I get mugged it's
wrong I should be able to do that but do
I have any sort of [__] personal
responsibility for my own [__] safety
all right you know we'll go to a
football practice she's got high heels
shoot she you know what first thing that
drops a girl's sex sex thing is down by
at least 30 percent is when they wear
those flats is that the worst when you
when you're in a relationship and they
get so comfortable that they stop
jacking their ass up yeah and they just
wear the flats and all of a sudden they
look like like they're a little clown
climbing out of a car yeah she should
have worn those you're doing you're
preaching the choir I I'm doing a bit
I'm doing in my bit a bit of my act
right now about take your lashes like
you chose this role and the the so why
are you defending this girl I'm saying
I'm I'm you convert you convinced me the
center busy the centerpiece of the the
bid is that is about this fat girl
cock-blocking me with the skinny girl
and doing the whole angry fat girl thing
and it's like okay yeah it's just like
you know I didn't eat all the egg
sandwiches you did that was your
decision okay you're gonna get mad at me
that I'm not leapfrogging over your hot
friend to get a shot at your michelin
man body right that way there's nothing
wrong with it you fat that's okay but
take the [__] hit sometimes you know
what I mean it's not fair to everybody
else you're waltzing around like you're
a piece of tail you're not you know yeah
yeah yeah they're like a walrus sunning
yourself at the bar yeah but my whole
thing too is like you're on part Arab if
I were a turban on an airplane I got to
be ready for a couple people to be like
I'm saying
territory yeah dude she is look I'm not
saying that she's a bad person she looks
like she's [__] gorgeous but she
doesn't she doesn't look like I looked
at her was that the shirt she was weird
that's the this is that's well that's
her at the Super Bowl but is that the
shot did the shot you showed me in the
in the actual article was the ass shot
is that what she looked like from the
front that is her I mean that's not her
at the practice but yeah that's what she
wearing she's wearing that nightclub top
she's got like the diamonds on the tit
on the hitch yeah glittery tit shirt
yeah it's ridiculous glittery tits
I mean look yeah you can't you got to
understand this is what pisses me off
Joe is its NFL football it's a guy sport
there's a bunch of guys playing it
nobody asks you to [__] come there
you inserted yourself into this
situation and this listen I'm repeating
myself in the podcast but just to hear
your opinion
that's when don't you hate that one if
bunch of guys hanging out you shooting
the [__] and we're talking then I'll
somebody said scuse me there's a lady
present and then all the fun just stops
yeah and everybody has to adjust their
[__] behavior because you're there
you know my favorite thing ever let me
hear some hate is when a like a waitress
will say that to a bunch of drunk guys
and there's always the 150 you know the
waitress will go like is that how you
talk in front of a lady
and and then there's always 150 year old
drug that goes well why don't you show
me a [__] lady and I'll tell you you
know it's such an old joke but it always
gets a left it always gets a left
it's just nothing you know somebody was
telling me when I was I was out in
Denver they were saying that they were
gray went out to go shoot pool right oh
shoot no I remember they were shooting
pool and there was you know they were
kicking the [__] out of these guys and
there was this group of guys they had
next right and then some girl kotti
comes up and she didn't want to [__]
wait she puts her money down but she's
so [__] hot that these other ball is
Jack asses they let her cut right nice
and then she's making this big one and
then she's just such a far a just an
arrogant [__] [__] that these guys
are like look we don't want to play we
don't to play you we're gonna play those
guys right and she gets bla bla bla bla
bla bla bla giving him [__] and he goes
look we're not playing you were playing
those guys and she took a full drink and
threw it in this guy's face so I go well
you can't hit him what do you do he goes
oh this guy's brilliant
he's a spitter he doesn't he just she
goes and she he was so [__] me she
goes what are you gonna do are you gonna
hit me
he goes no I'm not gonna hit he goes hit
her right in the chest and it rolled
down between her titties and this is the
worst part the bouncers come over
flipping them and they [__] of course
go and and those guys who she
cut all [__] ran if they do to just
did that [__] oh that's great just
immediately
yeah because spitting on somebody is so
much worse I've never much really get
blasted in the fatty I even take the
brain damage did you ever hear that
do you read that Tony Roberts joke where
he's like he's like [__] up to hit a
woman I would never hit her all right
I'm [__] he's like if you put your
hands on me I'll [__] lay out fine
don't do his whole bit go see Tony
Robert Smith he goes you see those
commercials all right yes every 12
seconds a woman is hit in this country
tea goes he goes they'll tell you how
every eight seconds there's a [__] in
your face going and he goes I warned you
[__] you had four seconds Tony Roberts
one of the most underrated comedians of
all time that guy is so [__]
ridiculously talented he's so funny yeah
I saw him accommodation typical
ridiculously talented dude he's
unbelievably humble I saw him on Comedy
Central and he I think he just starts
the bit like this he just goes and it
was so good because I [__] hate Wendy
Williams he goes Wendy Williams and
Danny Glover are the same [__]
person all right well we got to wrap up
the podcast here Joey squeaky little
voice that really just annoyed me oh
here's another YouTube video to watch go
to wimp comm bill dances classic
bloopers Joe I actually have to show you
this one this is like a guy trying to do
a fishing show and one of them I swear
to god I can't believe that it's
actually true he's going down the river
and in the distance the other cameraman
from the tube they're doing like a
two-shot the shoot the other cameraman
first of all is in the shot and he's
edging towards the bank to get a better
shop and it's an eight-foot drop into
the river and the guy with the kid falls
into the [__] River
and the what's-his-face he's one of
those redneck guys who he gets mad but
he's like a classy dude so he doesn't
curse so he uses like those redneck
exciter know what the [__] they are but
he's just ah
dagnabbit you know two goes in the water
I'm butchering it deep it's actually
it's [__] hilarious
hey I gotta hop in the shower cuz Bobbi
Kelly's meeting me here in a car chase
is Jo Bobby Kelly is he gonna come
walking through the door no he's gonna
ring the buzzer and I got a round so I
gotta get ready no no it's my show I
tell you when we're when we were up
against the hard break and it's time for
you to go where you going Joe you're
just gonna put it down you're just gonna
tap out and walk out all right no
problem Joe DeRosa everybody Joe DeRosa
has a new CD out that I would have hyped
but he walked away we'll give me the
height what's the height Joe when does
it come out now seriously Joe if it was
out people would be talking about it
when does it come out oh Jesus it's out
it's called the depression auction and I
endorse it Joe Darrell come on he did
one in here he burned a bit on the
podcast for you why am i yelling um
anyways I think that's gonna be the
podcast for this week I'm doing a ton of
media this week
fans of the Opie and Anthony program I
believe I'm gonna be on there definitely
tomorrow hopefully Wednesday I'm
basically gonna be on that show as many
days as they'll have me cuz I like those
sons of [__] that's it no seriously
and if you don't listen to the Opie and
Anthony program I don't know what your
problem is get an XM satellite whatever
the [__] Sirius XM player and check
those guys out watch a little bit of
their stuff on YouTube they're uh
they're [__] awesome so I'm gonna be
doing them this week I'll probably be
doing something on vs. and you know what
as I do them if they're not live and
they're gonna be shown later I'll just
on the mmm podcast we'll have that
information up there but if you didn't
get the og ringtone you can go to the
mmm podcast calm and on the left hand
corner you'll see it right there and you
just click on OGG and you can get it put
it in
your phone and then whenever the biggest
[__] in your life calls you up that's
what your phone's gonna be saying oh gee
oh if you don't don't do it
I don't give a [__] I'm just happy you
listening all right you guys have a
great week and that's my prediction
Ravens will win and I don't know Jets
Jets at Patriots I got to be honest with
you could go either direction but I'm
really liking what I watched on the
ticker-tape on the airplane I have no
[__] idea I missed I can't judge the
Patriots but uh and I think the Jets are
gonna get best mic go ten and six after
all that [__] yip-yap and they'll
probably make it into the playoffs God
knows they got and they got enough
talent on the [__] team but I think
all this [__] talking's really gonna
hurt him and I don't I don't think
they're gonna go as far as they went
last year what do you think about that
huh what do you think about that Jets
play like a jet what the [__] does that
mean
you haven't won one since 1969 what does
that mean get your fans all excited and
then you [__] the bed in January what
Joe that's what they do Joe they haven't
won since we were excited that we landed
on the moon like that was gonna lead to
new real estate that was the last time
they want Joe I was six months old Joe
six months old Curt Goudy announced the
last time that they won a Super Bowl all
right Jim Morrison was still alive Joe
Jimi Hendrix was still putting out
albums Joe DeRosa the last time they won
and this same play like a jet I like
that that sounds like one of the oldest
they're really into that old school [__]
you know what the sad thing about the
Jets are they're the only professional
Pancho's and all four sports that
actually sublets their stadium yeah if
they play a giant stadium there you know
what they are show they're like that
[__] loser who never moves out and
that window of getting married and
actually meeting somebody just closes
and then they just say [__] it and
they're just waiting for the last of
their Alive parent to die so that they
can think they can take over the house
Jesus Joe look at you coming with a
little bit of anger Joe you know what I
hate out unenchanted shamed you are
about your torso I give Joe [__] because
his body he looks like an adolescent
Will Ferrell like what picture Will
Ferrell's body at 23 Joe have you ever
done a pull-up in your life do you like
dude do you even have those muscles yeah
he left me I was really gonna compare
him to like the Camaro rally sport you
know somebody goes out you get the IROC
right you got the air conditioner you
got the t-tops you get the electric
windows and then he had the rally sport
which you basically had the same body
but you didn't have those options I was
going to go that route is that what you
were gonna do bill were you gonna do it
in a funny way because the way you
presented that it wasn't too funny all
right that's the podcast for this week
god bless all you guys let's go Ravens
[__] the Jets and I'm hoping this time
next week that Jets are [__] Owen too
and if they are Owen - I'm telling you
right now Rex Ryan I'm
guaran-fucking-tee it will cry during a
press conference and he's gonna be
crying and his [__] you know body's
gonna be jiggling I hate the Jets I hate
the Jets more than I hate the Colts now
you know kind of helps that they lost to
the Texans but I yeah the Jets I want
nothing more than to watch them eat
their [__] words the arrogance of
that [__] team look at that you don't
know how to behave when there's a lady
in the room all right who gives a [__]
Ravens are gonna win tonight I'm gonna
have an extra 50 bucks and the Patriots
are gonna beat him next week all right
that's what my heart says all right you
guys have a good week please watch my
special Sunday night September 19th 11
p.m. okay
[Music]
what's that
for nothing
[Music]
custom kitchen
we got the movie
[Music]
[Applause]